mit unserem universum stimmt etwas nicht
und zwar so richtig das ist auseinander
fliegt das steht seit 1927 fest und das
ist dabei immer schneller wird seit 1998
auch doch etwas ist dabei konstant naja
fast oder nicht oder so genau weiß man
das nicht die astronomie tappt
wahrhaftig im dunkeln denn je nachdem
wie man die hubble konstante die diese
expansion definiert misst kommt etwas
gänzlich anderes dabei raus kriegstanz
in future hier gibt es drei mal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los ganz herzlich
willkommen diese videos entstanden in
kooperation mit ricoh de dem digitalen
abos für smartphone oder tablet für nur
regulären 999 gibt es nahezu alle
magazine und zeitschriften der linken
und ami mit einem besonders günstigen
sonderangebot für euch hier unter dem
link gibt es die ersten beiden monaten
für nur jeweils einen euro 99 ab 39 eur
99 und es kann jederzeit gekündigt
werden und wir haben dieses mega
spannende thema dort auf video.de aus
spektrum sterne und weltraum
aber es gibt noch mehr als 5000 weiterer
magazine dazu auf wiki wie die ist wie
dass netflix für magazine
wissenschaftlich gesehen ist es eine
katastrophe denn umso genauer man den
wert der habe konstante bestimmen will
desto ungenauer werden die ergebnisse
oder unterschiedlicher das ist wirklich
paradox denn die messergebnisse werden
eigentlich immer genauer aber liegen
immer deutlicher auseinander aber wie
kann das sein
wie ist das unmögliche möglich und diese
tatsächlich ziemlich aussichtslose lage
der kosmologie die forschenden versuchen
bei jedem verfahren ein möglichst
exaktes ergebnis zu erzielen aber je
nach verfahren sind die ergebnisse
vollkommen anders
zur messung der expansion des universums
werden himmelskörper herangenommen von
denen man ganz exakt weiß wie hell und
wie heiß sie sind wie bei einem
leuchtturm weiß die forschung so viel
über diese himmelskörper dass sehr viele
weitere werte an ihnen bestimmt werden
können unter anderem eben die hubble
konstante denn sie beschreibt
geschwindigkeit mit der das universum
auseinanderfliegt und das tut das
universum mit zunehmender entfernung mit
immer höherer geschwindigkeit die hubble
konstante beschreibt deshalb auch keine
feste geschwindigkeit sondern die
zunahme der geschwindigkeit mit
steigender entfernung sie wird pro
megaparsec ermittelt das entspricht
einer entfernung von drei millionen
260.000 lichtjahren und dieser wert
liegt bei ja das kann ich einfach nicht
sagen
je nachdem wie man das mist kommt ein
anderes ergebnis raus namensgeber edwin
hubble lag bei seinen eigenen messungen
noch komplett daneben er hatte sterne
verwechselt und kam so auf ein ergebnis
von 500 kilometern pro sekunde und
megaparsec also pro megaparsec nahm die
geschwindigkeit laut habel pro
megaparsec um 500 km zu einer galaxie
also die ein megaparsec von uns entfernt
es würde sich nach hubbles berechnungen
mit 500 kilometern pro sekunde von uns
entfernt eine galaxie im abstand von
zwei megaparsec doppelt so schnell also
mit tausend kilometer pro sekunde und so
weiter und so fort
das prinzip scheint tatsächlich zu
gelten und wurde immer wieder bestätigt
nur der wert lag bei den ergebnissen von
habe komplett daneben sein fehler war
dass er andere sterne mit dem c frieden
verwechselt diese sterne verändern
periodische ihre leuchtkraft und größe
und mit hilfe der dauer der periode kann
ihre leuchtkraft definiert werden das
heißt dass man ihre helligkeit sehr
genau kennt und damit ihre entfernung
exakt bestimmen kann verwechselt man
diese sterne nun wie isabelle
unterlaufen ist dann kommt man zu
falschen ergebnissen da die leuchtkraft
mit der entfernung abnimmt was man damit
sehr genau wie weit entfernt sind die
geschwindigkeit kann jetzt durch die
rotverschiebung des lichts ermittelt
werden die setzt sich zusammen aus der
eigenen geschwindigkeit von objekten und
eben der expansion des universums für
beide gilt wenn sich objekte von uns
entfernen dann wird die frequenz
niedriger beim licht röther bei schalt
tiefer das kennen wir als dopplereffekt
vom vorbeifahren
autos mit martinshorn kommen sie auf uns
zu ist der ton hoch und entfernen sie
sich wird der ton tiefer
jetzt muss man die eigene
geschwindigkeit der sterne herausrechnen
und schon hat man die geschwindigkeit
mit der sich die sterne entfernen
weitere sterne bei denen man die
leuchtkraft genau kennt sind supernovae
vom typ 1a oder rote riesensterne wie
zum beispiel beteigeuze die an einem
exakt definierten punkt ihrer
entwicklung explodieren es gibt also
drei verschiedene arten von sternen bei
denen die astronomie so viel über sie
weiß dass sie entfernungen
geschwindigkeit exakt bestimmen kann
aber auch mit der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung oder
gravitationslinsen lässt sich die hubble
konstante bestimmen von all diesen
kosmischen phänomen gibt es so viele
informationen dass die hubble konstante
exakt bestimmt werden kann
und jetzt wird es frustrierend diese
exakten ergebnisse sind grundverschieden
erst anfang der zehnerjahre wurden die
daten des plank weltraumteleskops
veröffentlicht es lieferte die bislang
detailreichsten karte der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung und eine hubble
konstante von 67 74 kilometer pro
sekunde je megaparsec das spitzer
weltraumteleskop lieferte dagegen anhand
von zufrieden davor einen wert von 74,3
das hubble-weltraumteleskop wiederum mit
zufrieden und supernovae vom typ 1a 74,2
die beiden werte liegen ja wenigstens
einigermaßen beieinander und wenn man
berücksichtigt dass beide messungen eine
abweichung von plus minus 2,1 kilometer
pro sekunde und megaparsec mal spitzer
und 3,6 beim hubble-weltraumteleskop zu
lassen dann decken sich die ergebnisse
fast zunichte machen das aber wieder die
messungen an gravitationslinsen also so
starken gravitationsfeld zum beispiel um
galaxien die das licht von objekten wie
eine linse so stark rühmen dass galaxien
dahinter zwei oder sogar vier mal
auftauchen dabei legt das licht
unterschiedliche wege zurück zum einen
sind es tatsächlich umwege durch die
krümmung der raumzeit in der
gravitationslinse und zum anderen
unterliegt an lichtstrahl der durch den
dichteren teil der gravitationslinse zu
uns gelangt größeren relativistischen
effekten das heißt einer größeren zeit
dilatation die zeit im lichtstrahl läuft
langsamer das sind effekte von einigen
wochen und monaten dass er
ergebnis 69,7 kilometer pro sekunde und
megaparsec es ist wirklich zum mäuse
melken und es geht hier nicht um
irgendeine petitesse eine undichtigkeit
diese unterschiedlichen ergebnisse
stellen die gesamte kosmologie in frage
stimmt da etwa alles nicht was wir über
unseren kosmos wissen welche der drei
grundannahmen sind also falsch gilt die
relativitätstheorie nicht das ist mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
auszuschließen sie wurde in so unendlich
vielen praktischen versuchen immer
wieder bestätigt das ist nahezu
unmöglich gibt es etwa keine dunkle
materie oder stimmt etwas nicht mit der
dunklen energie für die dunkle materie
gibt es ja eine heiße spur wir haben ja
gerade erst mit professor günther
hasinger gesprochen
dem wissenschaftlichen direktor der esa
der schwarze löcher für die dunkle
materie hält und die dunkle energie
da gibt es ja die größten fragezeichen
könnte es hier durch die vereinigung von
quantenphysik und relativitätstheorie
eine neue sichtweise ergeben
ist es vielleicht ein feld das sind mehr
als in unseren bekannten vier
dimensionen existiert und dadurch
veränderlich ist denn wir dürfen nicht
vergessen umso weiter weg die gemessenen
objekte zur bestimmung der habe
konstante sind desto älter sind zäh und
damals könnte eben ein anderer wert für
die dunkle energie gegolten haben und
das würde bedeuten das wäre einem ganz
anderen universum leben als wir bisher
gedacht haben das thema stammt aus
wheatley de eine app die schon seit
geraumer zeit nutze man da wirklich
nahezu alles findet wie zum beispiel
hier die hubble krise in spektrum sterne
und weltraum allein für dieses magazin
lohnt sich schon das wird die abo und es
ist papier frei kein einziger baum wird
gerodet aber wie die gibt es auch
weitere mehr als 5000 magazine
das sonderangebot für euch gibt es hier
einfach draufklicken der link ist
übrigens auch in der video beschreibung
also drauf klicken und los geht s dann
bleibt dran